I think sometimes when you go through
traumatic things as a character your
mind knows that it's not real but your
body doesn't know that you're not going
through something really awful so there
there's a there is a point where it's
like you have to try to I have to get
better at calibrating for myself how to
go there but then be able to protect
myself afterwards so I don't need to be
hospitalized maybe that would be after
shooting American Horror Story working
with Ryan Murphy has been arguably the
the greatest experience of my life and
has borne a tremendous amount of my
acting fruit if that's a sentence one
can use but you know he continues to
come to me on American Horror Story
alone I've played I don't even know how
many I mean I did eight seasons of that
show and in one or two seasons I played
multiple characters sometimes a reprisal
of another character but in one season I
had two heads so you know there was um
he just continues to throw me
opportunities to play to stretch my
acting muscle and and also I think his
giving me the greatest gift which is not
just the opportunity to work but he's
he's already given the audience freedom
and permission to not expect one
particular thing from me which I think I
think allows people to accept me I hope
allows people to accept me in different
parts even ones that they have you know
you if you're on a show for seven or
eight years playing the same character
that people love and you tried to as an
actor step outside of that and play
something else in a in a movie or
another television show sometimes the
audience gets very protective of it and
they resist it whereas on American
Horror Story I've played so many
different parts and it's part of what
the audience likes about watching the
show is seeing all the different actors
playing different things every year and
I think it allows for more elastic
creativity and a willingness on their
part to to buy it when we play something
different because they're already
they're already down with that and that
means hopefully I'll get to do I'll get
to work into my dotage in a way that
maybe would be harder if if there was a
certain assignment put on me about what
I what I can or can't do you know the
most challenging thing I've ever done an
American Horror Story was playing bat
and dot
because you know I'm one person and I
have one head and and I was playing
someone who had two of them and they
were they had very disparate
personalities yet they shared a body
it was the scenes Jessica Lange hated
shooting shooting more than anything
because she'd be like oh are we shooting
with the twins today we'll be here for
20 hours and a big thanks lady and she's
like well it's not you it's just it's 20
yeah it's just we've just it just it
just increased the length of our day and
because you had to do everything twice
it was really really challenging just
from a physical standpoint sometimes we
would have a puppet that I would be for
a while they had someone else trying to
manipulate the puppeteering and it was
just too confusing so I started doing it
so I kind of became a part-time
puppeteer because I would know when to
rotate the opposing way if I lived one
way and wanted her to look the other way
because he wouldn't the puppeteer
wouldn't know what I might be doing but
the character I was playing it was very
heavy and we were shooting in New
Orleans it's very hot and all the green
screen stuff you know we were having to
it was just within a millimeter of
matching - it was just really hard and
you know I one time I've talked about
this a million times though like where I
had to write with one hand but then act
with another so I was playing one
character but my body was doing the body
reference for the other part that I was
playing it was an actual nightmare but I
am very proud of having done it I don't
think anyone had ever done what we did
on that show even from a special effect
standpoint at that point so it was a
pretty pretty extraordinary achievement
for everyone I think I think sometimes
when you go through traumatic things as
a character your mind knows that it's
not real but your body doesn't know that
you're not going through something
really awful and it's something that
would happen to me a lot on American
Horror Story and and where I often spend
a lot of time in peril or running or
screaming or crying
finding your body doesn't know that you
aren't really being chased and I suppose
if I were a different kind of actor I
could fake it better but I don't know
how to do that so I'm not the kind of
person that will like do a scene where
I'm being pursued by a clown and then I
get up after we they yell cut and I'm
just like what's for dinner you know I'm
the girl in the corner shaking you know
so there there's a there is a point
where it's like you have to try to I
have to get better at calibrating for
myself how to go there but then be able
to protect myself afterwards so I don't
need to be hospitalized immediately
after shooting it's real adrenaline and
your your body you know you are really
asking yourself to go somewhere very
specific so that you can simulate for
the audience that this is something
you're going through but I don't know
how to do it in a way that feels like a
simulation to me so that that that costs
you something but I wouldn't trade it
for anything I mean I wouldn't trade it
for anything playing Lana winters prior
to playing Marcia Clark that was the
most extraordinary experience I ever had
in terms of what I felt about the
character the barometer for it is like
how devastated I am when it's over you
know that was one of those years on
American Horror Story where I wished I
could have just continued to play her
remind me of your name Lana winters can
I ask what Shelly did I assumed you were
punishing her for something I assumed
you were here to do a story on a bakery
Oh believe me no one loves that molasses
bread more than I do played her through
several ages you know but you know that
was I don't remember how old I was at
the time but I played someone in there I
played Lana in her 70s by the end of
that series so I basically spanned a
whole lifetime with this character I
don't imagine
my AG be much interested in this I've
thought about this and so I got very
attached to it and um and it was very
hard to say goodbye sometimes that
happens where you get a weird blurred
line if you don't know where you stop
and the character begins and it feels
very it's like a haunting almost you've
been haunted by a character and it's
hard to you need an exorcism to kind of
get them out I don't know I you know
Milana thing I think it was my first
time or I had a real leading role on
something and where I was so integral to
the story and Ryan had really trusted me
with it and you know again she I stand a
lifetime with her so it almost felt like
a life I had lived and I had that with
Lana winters I had that with Marcia
Clark and I just had that with Mildred
rachet American crime story the People
vs OJ Simpson playing Marcia Clark was
probably - at this point in my career
the greatest opportunity I ever had and
it was something I really ended up
learning a great deal about myself as an
actor when I played that part because I
didn't realize I had only up until then
although I had played real people I had
never had such a surplus of information
and I never played a character a
real-life character that was that was so
integral to the plot the the people
versus OJ was had a lot to do with you
know sort of Marcia's story and our and
the misrepresentation of Marcia's story
in the media during that time good
morning miss Clark I think
I had so much information to to dive
into and draw upon and try to bring
forward that I realized that as an actor
I actually really prefer playing people
real people because then there's such a
foundational blueprint for me to to
source where I don't have to wonder what
a character would do in a moment I have
all this information that tells me
because sometimes when you're creating a
character out of whole cloth or with a
writer and a director out of your
imagination any choice you make could
work but when you have a blueprint you
can really really make confident choices
and decisions that you can really stand
behind which I think I think then ends
up creating a more confident performance
not because you think you're doing such
a great job but because you can really
get behind your choices in a way where
you're not ever wondering oh well I
guess I could do it this way I could be
more angry I could be more injured I
could be I could very clearly say oh no
she would just be pissed here or she
would feel forsaken here or unseen here
you know there there was so much for me
to to play with yeah in a way that I
find really soothing and ultimately very
peaceful making rather than stressful
making although I did worry about
getting it right for her and not
disappointing her and and and all of
that even though she wasn't involved in
it so there was no way to really know
this same DNA match the blood you found
on the back gate at Bundy yes it does
and does it match the blood you found
inside mr. Simpson's Bronco yes it's all
from the same individual and does it
match the DNA and the blood you found
leading up to mr. Simpson's house and on
the stock at the foot of his bed I mean
doing those courtroom scenes as Marcia
Clark we were in that room with the
lights on you know with everybody behind
us that was there every day where there
was a background artist or a member of
the cast that was playing someone that
day who was just watching Plus all the
jury was there every day it was like
walking into a real courtroom and it was
an absolute visceral experience well any
time we had to get up there and you know
sterling or I or even someone on the
opposing side having to get up and give
our closing arguments or interview or
cross-examine someone you're doing it in
front of all these people just like they
were and she just was a fascinating
woman and I didn't want to say goodbye
to it it just I got
really confused when I was playing her
like am i she or is she me or em it was
just weird studio 60 studio 60 was my
first sort of sparkly job and it was the
show that every single actor intent like
every actor in town was auditioning for
this and and um you know because it's
Aaron Sorkin and so it was really
exciting you know Matthew Perry had just
finished friends Bradley Whitford had
just come off the West Swing it was
Aaron Sorkin it was a very
nerve-wracking scary time I got into the
Falstaff Society hey great are you the
first woman I'm cool I am from the Great
Lakes region
you're quite a pioneer I am being
inducted Saturday night and I need to
tell a joke we did a lot of walking
talks on that show everybody was kind of
making fun of that component of it which
was much like The West Wing and other
Aaron Sorkin shows as well but if there
was a contraction if it was wouldn't
instead of would not and you said would
not or if the reverse were true there
was a woman whose job it was on set we
called her the hawk Matthew Perry called
her the hawk because she would come up
to you and you know you would have done
a long walk and talk that took you know
I don't know a single take all the way
down the hallway and then you'd see
Wendy like walk towards you and you're
just like Matthew would be like ha ha
because you know you would think you
really for saying wouldn't instead of
would not and Aaron I think was a major
to musical theater or it was a music
major in college so he was he's really
focused on the rhythm of something so
you could always tell when he was happy
or unhappy with something you had done
and it was usually around the rhythm of
it and the and part of the rhythm of it
was designed to have every word that was
therapy for a very specific purpose so
it was almost Shakespearean in terms of
the way it was written and you just
really had to learn your lines to the
letter to the comma period to the
contractions it was really specific
especially because it was early I was
barely 30 years old when I did that that
show and it was sort of earlier on in my
career and I had come from a sort of dry
spell of not working and we'd been doing
some theater in New York and
and it was it was nerve-racking because
you don't want Aaron to not be pleased
with you and also you do know that from
from an acting standpoint you're only as
good as your text and when you have
texts like that you just you're already
ahead of the game but I think sometimes
I was when I look back and watch it I'm
like oof I can tell I was so scared of
messing up the lines that that it was
sometimes hard it just felt it the whole
thing felt a little nerve-wracking but
but I also did think wow if they want me
to be here if I'm included in this group
then maybe maybe I have a future 12
years of slave but I played mistress
Epps and twelve years a slave which was
probably one of the harder things I've
ever had to do in terms of the way
playing something makes you feel after
doing it there was a cruel teacher her
there was a although it was my
responsibility and Steve McQueen's
desire for me to not judge the character
at all because he didn't think it would
help serve the story or me or my
portrayal if I was judging her too
harshly but it was very hard to go to
work every day knowing that I had to
treat Lupita the way I did trying to
reorganize my own personal beliefs to
stand behind something I really found
abhorrent about her Phil will you master
master name my friend was he a learning
man I suppose so
he learned you to read a word here or
there but I've no understanding of the
room don't trouble yourself with it same
as the rest master bought you here to
work that's all any more learn you a
hundred lashes but I just I just knew
that I had a real part to play in the
story the telling of this story that if
I didn't lean into it or if I try to
soft-pedal it it wouldn't have helped
the overall narrative and so my job was
to help depict the terrible life they
were living and it wouldn't have helped
that story at all if I had tried to
engender some kind of kindness between
me and the audience it just I don't
think it
would have gone well which is something
that after playing that part I have sort
of decided can be a wonderful part of
what you get to do as an actor it was
through playing this part that it kind
of cemented this belief in me that you
know we all have a responsibility as
performers to try to shed light on human
behavior and try to reflect back some of
what we encounter in our own lives and
sometimes that isn't a pretty picture
and we all have people in our lives or
have dealt with people in our lives who
or we all if we're honest with ourselves
have certain qualities that aren't
pretty and that are sometimes
self-motivated and I do think if you're
going to tell a sort of three
dimensional if you're going to try to
paint a three-dimensional portrait of a
person you have to have the underbelly
to and I do think sometimes it's hard
because in the industry you you in order
to get more jobs you you try to make
sure that the audience is on your side
or you know but because I I feel like I
play more character parts I feel like I
have more latitude to kind of go to some
some darker places without worrying
whether people walk out of there liking
me or not you know because my job is
actually there's a larger responsibility
there in terms of just trying to help
tell the story
oceans eight oceans eight was just so
fun I mean I've never been on a set
probably with more than one woman at a
time in a story that I might be part of
telling usually there's a couple of guys
and one lady and I think we all kind of
marveled at how unique it was to be on a
set in everywhere you looked your scene
partner was a woman you're doing here I
thought you were in jail and I got out
look at all this thought you retired I
did not as exciting as hijacking trucks
that are smuggling dishwashers from
Canada right yeah well I don't do that
anymore so very good thank you so these
are all for personal use right what do
you want and we all remarked how how
that had rarely been the case and
and how wonderful it was and what an
extraordinarily great fun dynamic it
created what a wonderful makeup trailer
it was and the things that we all talked
about we're so you know family and
friendship and motherhood and it just it
was a really extraordinary set to be a
part of and obviously working with some
of the most celebrated actresses and you
know Rihanna she's she's the greatest
and she's also Rihanna like I think all
of us were it was a real highlight for
all of us I think I was the only nerd
who like couldn't I would sing in front
of her anyway and you know everyone
would just stand behind me like I'd be
like I tried to come up with songs for
her new album and she wasn't that
interested in them and I don't I'm not
quite sure why I thought some of them
were really catchy game change game
change was another job that came to me
really after a weird dry spell I had a
lot of like fits and starts like a
sputter ECAR in my career in the
beginning of it and it came after a
drought and it was the second time in my
career where I was told by the director
that it was there the third time that
happened in studio 60 as well I was told
that the wives of the directors are the
ones who insisted that it be me when it
came down between me and another actress
that happened on 12 years of slave game
change and studio 60 women are smarter I
guess and they just you know I remember
Christine Lahti telling me she's married
to Tommy salami who directed studio 60
and she was the one it was between me
and other actors who I won't name but
who's incredibly good and I think it was
a real it was a real neck-and-neck thing
and apparently it was Christine Lahti
who and it was Susanna Hoffs who's
married to Jay Roach for Game Change
she's just the lead singer of the
bangles you guys it's no big deal she
was there was another actress there
about to cast who I think looked more
like Nicole Wallace and my tape came in
quite late and so it was Susanna Hoffs
apparently who pushed Jay Roach into
going with me and then I think it was
Steve McQueen's daughter in 12 years a
slave who was like watch my take I was
like Daddy she really scares me and he
was like I should probably cover for
that one so Julianne Moore to me is
arguably one of our greatest actresses
I was totally freaked out to work with
her but it was it was very stabilizing
that the first time I met her was not as
Julianne Moore it was as Sarah Palin and
my character was supposed to be kind of
stunned by the experience of meeting her
to memorize these answers I'm sure
you're going to nail this interview how
do you know he'll ask he's it was the
White House communications director it's
my job to figure out the questions first
really Saakashvili the president of
Georgia so she could severely
soccer's she's with Saakashvili hawkish
Vili let me ask you about some specific
national security situation let's start
with Russia in Georgia do you believe
the United States should try to restore
Georgian sovereignty over South Ossetia
and Abkhazia so that was a very helpful
reality for me that I think the first
time I met Julie was in an elevator on
her way up to rehearse a scene and she
was already fully fully in the in the
Palin look so that really house so she
listened to her iPod a lot and I think
she was listening to Sarah's you know
speech pattern a lot but she could she
was not one of those actresses who was
sort of be in the corner
you know like barriers around her while
she prepares to do something she can
she's really remarkable that way there
was a big scene in that first script
that was not there in the in the final
product there was a big scene that was
not there in the first script which is
something that Nicole had told them
happened that they didn't find out about
until later which was that Nicole didn't
vote and that was a sort of moving scene
in that in that show where I come up to
what Harrelson and I tell him that I
couldn't I couldn't vote even though it
was a member of my own party and that I
had been campaigning for her McCain and
I couldn't bring myself to vote for him
because of her
I didn't vote I couldn't do that was a
very illuminating piece of information
to have and and when Danny strong who
wrote that when we were talking about it
he said I think I have to put that in
the script and so so he did which was
great because it was you know the thing
about playing a real live person whose
job it was she was a communications
director for the White House so she she
had a lot of on-camera things for me to
see I could go on YouTube and see but I
could only see the public side of her
and the what I was trying to bring to
life was was the private side of her and
I had nothing to reference and I
remember talking to Jay Roach about
whether or not I should try to replicate
her voice and he said you know the thing
is is that Nicole's really there I mean
she was obviously a big part of what
happened but she's she's our eyes into
the behind the scenes of this she's the
audience so if you try to create a
physical and vocal replica of her I fear
that because she's not as well known as
the pale invoice and the McCain voice
it'll be too much of that and I think we
need to have a way into the story that
feels more personal and our way through
that story is isn't through Nicole's
character so so I didn't do anything to
try to adopt any physical communication
of her self at all
the Goldfinch the Goldfinch was um
something that I had wanted to do I had
loved the book and I had said out loud
in my bed at night that I would love to
play this part if they ever made a movie
and I I didn't know that I was a
believer in manifestation but I did wish
for it and I wish for it out loud and it
did come true so that was a sort of wild
thing and John Crowley our director I
don't think envisioned me because he had
watched two people versus OJ and I think
he could only see me as Marcia Clark
which happens sometimes and so I put on
a wig and a trashy outfit and got a
spray tan and went in and made an
audition tape and I guess convinced him
that I could do it that was a very
rewarding experience for me to know that
somebody had an idea about me that that
made them I mean almost say no we
wouldn't we don't even want her to come
in she's not right and I I was able to
change their minds with my auditions so
it means I did something there that made
him see me in an entirely different way
which which means I guess I was able to
transform myself in a way that made me
feel like a real actor and that's the
job to me I'm at I'm actually an actor
who likes to work from the outside in so
it's always about the costume and the
way the hair Falls and what the hair
color is going to be and what my shoes
are and then all of a sudden oh I can
figure out how to walk and you know
Xandra wore these insanely high shoes
and these very tight jeans you know just
the opposite of what I wear I would like
to wear a giant bag at all times and she
just it was incredibly body conscious in
a way that was so far from my comfort
zone that it actually made me walk
different I walked more pitched forward
and my ass was out and you know my butt
you know it's just a different way of
carrying myself and none of that is
something I could have pre-planned it
was something that happened to me when I
put on the costume I always like to work
that way and that's why you know when
you're lucky enough to work with
extraordinary costume designers I work
with Ann Roth on the post and you know
she she wanted a pocket for in a
particular dress I was wearing just in
case I needed a Kleenex in it for this
one scene you know and so it and she
thinks you know a lot of great designers
think like actors and
and they're imagining themselves in that
environment and what they would want and
what you would really need and not just
coming up with that with an outfit that
looks great but something that is useful
if you're playing a person who is at
home a lot and you're cooking for your
children you don't want to be wearing
something overly tight you're what you
know real people buy clothes that suit
their lives usually and so when you when
you work with really wonderful people
who think like that it helps just it
does half of your job for you and it's
incredibly exciting
[Music]